[Music]
now that was me
very nice part dammit hi married you
fart they can see your stupid mouth
it wasn't my mouth hi everyone welcome
back to Bethel this is the show where we
play through all the resin evil games
here on GameSpot I'm like my Hardy
that's Mary quiche
we're in res evil to remake this is our
tenth playthrough I messed that for
every time I think it's after eleventh I
don't know yeah such a wonderful array
[Music]
we know I said Miriam this is from the
Resident Evil era yeah sure Oh
altogether nice I don't want to take
away from any one piece because I think
they're so beautiful but I was so
impressed that we got such a wonderful
like a range that I wanted to go through
them piece by piece so on the far left
from mathy the survival horror which is
from two episodes ago where I was eaten
by a zombie and we saw mr. X and you
ripped your headphones off they scream
so loud but I like what it says it says
from the horrors of Mary's laundry room
and the giant palmistry room yeah like
this is my [ __ ] vacuum I like forgot
to take another shot like I mean so
embarrassed
I don't think oh I see
never mind that just drape to like hide
it but it wasn't long enough and I
haven't like done anything with my life
anyway following that just in love with
David J Hart's piece that is a ad for a
submachine gun in the lower right here
that was meant to be it's like made to
look like it was actually from the
Raccoon City Gazette that was
in the like firefight because you can
see some blood in it here but I love
that it is you described it as falling
on the sidewalk and people walked on it
yeah right here great against dogs then
you see you see a bunch of our end jokes
on the left as if it says like a let me
see oh right shotgun shells in the
morgue there's a few quotes there yeah
shotgun shells in the morgue to check
his pulse
your Nazi girl then there's or Oh for
[ __ ] sake probably if it was you I
think but you know now with the kendo
gun shop which is the resonable to
gunshot I love forget amazing and then
that one also inspired the these dogs
are getting effed in the a comic from
it's a gee I love this one so much it's
got you laughing at me randomly ethereal
being it's brilliant
yeah he puts out such good work he even
also like sometimes he'll show his
outlines which I just love I think
they're amazing
yeah progress yeah so incredible stuff
from sage and then it would be a mistake
to not mention dan from umbrella with no
leg day Birkin wait and you I don't
think I saw this one yet I did not
because he's so top-heavy yeah and then
yeah Johnny Bravo's head is on his chest
that's really good yeah I didn't see
yeah we I mean we just get so many and
love them all so thank you so much for
sending these in and letting us enjoy
them they're absolute they're just
delightful delightful
everyone what do it it's like they just
captured my lack of eyes when I smile I
don't mean that sarcastic
soul your very soul there you are
I was kidding you son of a [ __ ] okay
let me try to line up with that I don't
want to make you rearrange thought never
mind I got a haircut since then I was
talking today about how I really like my
haircuts until I noticed that 16 yeah
literally every other white guy I see
has the same haircut shave them asides
my beards were luscious my facial hair
screencap wait huh yeah if you laugh
naturally this is the show where play
games don't worry newcomers before we
start recording there might be a chance
that we go like 4550 minutes just
because I it was my fault that we
started late I was finishing up other
stuff but who knows we'll see how it
where it goes your important things to
do so we've got I don't wanna get like
too freaked out here but I have I have
two full heels so that's pretty good
what is I don't even remember what the
last thing we did was okay oh no no
sorry weren't sewer
yeah don't don't say that if you don't
know I don't know oh yeah it's okay
totally um yes man okay so it begins
yeah you haven't gone thinking I can't
just press that little press the bar see
the bar across the door you gonna push
on that I'm just kidding yeah yeah you
got a lot up it just wasn't compared to
the roller coaster before that I killed
dogs I think this is John's men men oh
you didn't know you should go down there
now oh yeah I meant like in general go
down there those are for yeah you can
just anything else should I get some
acid rounds no no no I don't I don't I
don't think you need like I don't think
it's gonna be a boss right now it just
happens to be somewhere you drop down I
think
no but we'll see well you don't have a
shotgun in general yeah I think you're
good you have 71 submachine gun rounds
in 36 hitting hours I think you're
completely fine right now
if not we'll figure it out later
your ability to help me has come have
been coming into question recently I
know I'm surprised it took this many
seasons people are questioning oh that's
a boss that's a boss that's a boss no
I'm just joking what is this what is
that do you hear it mm-hmm sound good
sounds like someone's is it loud enough
you can hear that right
sounds like someone's sick lashing in
the watery can you hear me sherry don't
don't [ __ ] with me sherry side of the
toilet I will shoot you between your
little girl eyes I'll ship you the
grenade yeah yeah maybe let her tell the
jokes Mary I am NOT going to not be
funny I will be a clown every day
yeah I was gonna say keep an eye on
those trash piles there's ammo and [ __ ]
on there every once in a while I hate
that yeah
they did a really good job if I must say
you possible I just like you can move
the objects in the water with the
bottles and [ __ ] it looks really rush
you can are the original game no is that
[ __ ] it's like you're in the Pope's seat
girl definitely poop I'm no doctor but
that's a big pile of [ __ ] I'm no doctor
but did you [ __ ] you why why is there
even a hole there like why fire see
wisher you never forget
[Music]
my nightmare they seem like some sort of
stairs
I just feel like it's been too quiet
[Music]
just thinking it over doesn't seem like
he wants to come out here shoot them
it's just a small area my concern is
that they're gonna attack me well let me
just make sure you're facing him then
you could l1 his ass Oh slam Alvin do it
fast oh you shot the door over this
second time sign orders wearing ties oh
where that third guy comes from
oh not too shabby I'd like a plaid one
of them is still alive
and possibly all of that I do not I have
those I don't throw that yeah okay we've
had mishaps with flashbangs in the past
don't do that
just you might walk up from an elf ooh
dude number two
getting up you're fine on mo you got 13
his necks broken trust me I would know
stay on the ground uh more like a valley
girl and I hate it I hate that so
[ __ ] cool when you see that do not
get up again where's my wine cooler
where's my [ __ ] Hey
stay down Hey just go on chill thank you
my goodness all right I checked those
lockers
[Music]
wait are you just guessing it's not hug
hey I'll mark that off write it down
show you down I think that's the only
place you can go right well there was
paper oh hey you picked it up I did I
don't think so oh wait their alarms
going off all over nests I don't know
what's going on but I can okay situation
here is dire nuts has been contaminated
the virus unbelievable the fouth Isis
meeting oh is this the worker outside I
can't believe in magic okay
director Owens you it was you all
director Owens you it what's new all
okay cool I absorbed everything good all
right I'm going down going down towns
don't it said don't go down what do you
mean I was kidding
I only have eight bullies this is like a
dangerous thing going on here gonna come
back up it doesn't look like whoa
some sort of room chery chery house it
was safe there
hey Shari I was scared
those things were every word and you
should have called the police but nobody
came you didn't answer your phone I
don't have time for this getting caught
in a domestic situation here yeah Jerry
Jerry I'm coming hold on Shari
I'll be right there dad hey remember
when we recorded in San Francisco and
every once in a blue moon I would leave
to go to the bathroom you don't remember
oh I took a bathroom really fast don't
change my lower third or anything I'll
be right back okay bye I'm really where
do you think his face would go
it was probably around here I was like
probably around here
stupid done thank you for your interest
in Knights construction company the past
20 years we have had the honor of
working in the sewer systems on your
great city's KCC
[Music]
pleasant is upon
all right I don't know what that's all
about
this is kind of like a another safe
space so I think what I'll do I drop
from here and yeah I drop them here
that's how to leave I think I'm actually
not sure I lost the thing that tells you
how to unlock the door to the you area
during that last mad dash of transfer I
know you have to stick one plug into
each terminal but if anyone remembers
which plug goes where please be a pal
and share the posting info on this board
pretty sure the rook and Knight are on
the same wall and the bishop and Queen
aren't next to each other the Queen and
the rook are opposite each other - what
am i [ __ ] talking about
is this like a puzzle for this so I need
a bunch of circuit oh this is a puzzle
[Music]
okay sorry no you're fine I'm just gonna
not that I accomplished very much I'm
gonna save and then I'm gonna tell you
what happened okay so I think I'm in a
puzzle piece here there's a couple
things going on mm-hmm
I assume although I don't know that if I
go this is locked right it's not alright
I have no idea what I'm doing
mm-hm all right here's the map so
there's a puzzle here go into here the
bishop plugin night plug and everything
yeah you know that you're not gonna
solve it anytime soon that's like the
overarching puzzle Oh
so should I put those back oh no this
says pretty sure the rook and the knight
are on the same wall and the bishop and
queen aren't next to each other the
Queen and the rook we're opposite of
each other to worry about those things
what don't worry about like those clues
yet you need to get like all the pieces
and they're like scattered throughout
the sewers so I'm just gonna put them
here for now just to get not have them
on me
right
yes sure wait I'm sorry yes you have the
right idea I want to make sure you don't
need any of them
I don't see why and then I I need to go
get sherry so unless I need this
gunpowder probably you can get rid of
those teas by the way people keep
getting annoyed that you have those
thumbs the chapters I don't see the big
deal yeah go back for a second they're
mine they're right
[Music]
that a dead guy
that's a red plant that's a dead man
that's water
get up you idiot
get up
yeah I've been drinking a polar Seltzer
waters all day are those yeah yes there
we have a fridge here the weirdest thing
to brag about yeah we have a fridge
no that's a fat zombie he was drinking
beers up here and he spilt his bucket uh
what should I do
there's a lot for me to do here there's
also this space over here you don't
think that mr. X comes around here do
you
no what's his name William Birkin like
tore him apart yeah but yeah yeah what
was that
he's uh I think he's going for a while
shut up
okay there's a lot going on here yeah
open up a little bit coordination is
written on the side of the safe and
chalk oh [ __ ] that's right oh no that's
a safe sorry I'm thinking of that was
the combo there's a safe right across
here is that what it's talking about
yeah I think so
you ever use chalk like on the sidewalk
when you're a young driveway I used to
draw a massive now I'm just kidding
that's on the other side of thing
unbelievable left to right twelve left
eight okay right eight sixteen left to
do left to right twelve left eight uh an
X
who is that Formica not the one you have
equipped but yeah the other one must be
the feds or something you ever see three
yes what did I see what the three ninjas
I think so
was it three like white kids yes is all
right I mean there are four yeah
ol Cobian was in the agate mountain and
you know they're not dad we both know
[Music]
there's a herb should get that but but
what is that did you hear it
yeah
while they both know how oh no it's just
one dude needs a rag no no wait wait
wait wait but stop it
sit down Punk I think with down to him
like three times
oh right in the dick it was an
accidental dick yeah well we all have
accidental dicks mine wasn't on purpose
if you know what I mean what is that
like that you're jumpy and alert but you
shouldn't be this jump
I'm not going down there that's that's a
just a shortcut from what I remember
back to where you were a long time ago
the sewers are labyrinthian and design
sneaking inwards on each other routing
back on each other okay
I love crafty and nightmare stop okay
thank you
still don't have a valve for that door I
have a valve
oh wait really oh when did you get that
maybe when you were taking a big dumber
I did poop a lot
[Music]
stay open or what you
oh sorry yes it does [ __ ] it's so dark
in here
there's a man's Oh looks terrible Oh
sewers look like Jesus Christ I'm so
sorry I keep [ __ ] bashing this desk
yeah sewers are gross
throbbing shut up I was laughing at a
text I got no should I go down there new
first place you can go right now um I
would go up yes away from the dirty
zombie infested water I mean I don't
want to go to the zombie infested water
that is true
stop making noise I'm not [ __ ] little
bird things I hate them oh this is
broken great well we're going back down
well it's either zombie infested water
or back where I came from which is fine
because I do need to put stuff away I
would yeah at least speaking from
experience I don't think you're going to
the water yet I've never played this
game before but speaking from experience
got a lot of good zingers against you
today today yeah should I just go
through the water
or no yeah so I I believe the way you
just looked to the right once you drop
it it's pretty rough so that's like a
valuable short yeah there's the poop
poll yes so you want to go the other way
oh no you're gonna back to the box I get
ya back to the boxes to drop some [ __ ]
off confused
this is a labyrinth isn't it alright so
actually this might have been not the
quick way this might have been a long
way now that I'm looking at it cuz look
how far I have - all right
should i I think I should make some
bullets dude I'm a little low here yeah
done especially I would say I don't
think actually you could combine that
red herb with yeah alright and then I
could store this blue might as well
upgrade to your older handgun with those
parts but I don't understand why would I
upgrade the older gun um I don't know
specifics it might be technically better
once you upgrade it but
okay and I am suppose I can't I can't
combine these you I don't think it would
let you oh yeah you're right it's not
lit up yeah all right so that's so okay
yeah maybe you know what over over it
just to see what it says and can fire
high-powered rounds in addition to
nine-millimeter oh it can oh wait it can
fire oh wait yeah I guess so maybe that
is your Magnum no no no no no who's the
expert here how about you all right I'm
gonna take out some gunpowder and make
some bullets okay how do I sort again
TouchPad oh alright hey some couple
gunpowder's buddy yeah regular gunpowder
with a regular dump I will make regular
handgun rounds so let me ask you this
should I put I don't need both of these
guns no which I would just take the the
one you just upgraded it should be fine
so that has high-powered in it right now
right I don't know yeah so that's I'm
trying to see it looks like a it looks
like you have the high-powered rounds in
there did it give you four did you put
something in there to give you freehand
uh high-powered rounds the ammo is it
looks yellow but it doesn't mean that
it's fancy ammo what I think you should
be I don't think you need those flame
rounds right now yeah you yeah okay
and also I probably get rid of the frag
grenade
you've got enough defensive items for
the flashbangs it's a frag defense
mm-hmm I mean it can also throw it but
yeah it's more I believe as it was well
as a defense in like the history of
America
if I'm an American history we can get
into it alright is that the employee
closet or locker room or something key
that you can examine from yeah oh the
night slug oh wait it does hold on are
you looking up a guide on your phone no
mixing your mom's lecture no I wish I
know I said that if it was a knock but
it's not because people who text their
moms are awesome
my mom texted me earlier today I haven't
responded text your mom you'd see me ma
texted I text her back right now Lucy
James text from her as well that could
be NDA
my mom Oh Lucy no she's a co-worker
talking about like Kingdom Hearts or
something weird
hey just so you know the new blood just
so you know I got a copy of this vision
tip and happy Park is game corner calm
and giving it an unfavorable review all
right so should I go down here it sounds
like I need to go to zombie land you're
pretty much gonna have to did you go up
those stairs yet straight ahead
those yeah that's when the broken one is
either right yeah sounds you're going
into the mall
where are they
look at that herb go pick it up listen
go get that you'll be fine do you hear
the breathing no don't act like you
don't [ __ ] hear the breathing oh
[ __ ] here [ __ ] you don't tell me what
I hear breathing it's like moaning it's
kind of kinky if you [ __ ] me you would
have gotten in if I wasn't here you're a
[ __ ] think you're safe where did the
thing you go I've seen alien it's in the
poop is that guy dead yeah I think so
there's only one way to find out girl
what is that
I should have saved
you gone no I don't want to I don't want
to
[Music]
no do ya you gotta go I just don't feel
like you're completely fine Oh untie
this is a boss
god damn it dude
[Music]
Hey
what is that your employee
oh wait no stop
don't waste around wait till the I open
there you go is open I know
lucky
I'm not I'm not ready for this fight
screw the I don't think much I'm not
prepared you got a hand gun around to
shoot it I don't don't worry about those
things just keep moving I got five more
you're good
just keep moving okay you're safe
well it is good that you took out at
least one though cuz you'll be back
there I didn't take out one yes you did
you killed the first one I did yeah you
kill the first one then a number two and
three came along you it's it's really
[ __ ] cool do you notice how when she
has high-powered rounds loaded and she
like rest on her wrist it's like it
doesn't make sense cuz you have more
control when you're holding it with your
hand I think I don't know people who I
fired handgun or I'm not an expert I
feel bad
yeah they put a lot of like good minor
detail and everything didn't they you're
like how
at least when Leon is reloading his
handgun he like tucks the flashlight
under his chin ah this room ever so this
where you get the King plug in the night
plug or Bishop plug or something no king
and queen
[Music]
it's a little more complicated but it's
not crazy hard puzzle to solve so that's
the bishop right it closed the door that
you just came through yeah but it's more
like it's it's here in this room oh wait
no that's the one he's picked up that
wasn't a bishop plug was it yeah sure I
should investigate this area right yeah
I'd say thirty Seconds to Mars in a long
time I just was singing kings and queens
of promise because you had a queen plug
you know the song we were the kings and
queens I promise
Jared Leto thirty Seconds to Mars that's
where my head is
you know the logical place I just don't
get are you talking to the audience now
our meet who's him where's your head at
I'm saying I don't get Jared Leto and
because Oh Jared Leto yeah he's weird
oh wait there's one in there what's the
one who's passed oh that's the queen
plug he's put in yeah I would go up the
stairs but then I can't plug isn't
really suggestive all right you oh oh I
can't make that joke all of a sudden
okay
leave the jokes I'm gonna shoot you like
a dog does I have my dog gone out is
this your Chinese food box pick it up
all right I'm calling it 604 dead
there's one don't jump on you Hans Hans
bender died at the age of who the [ __ ]
cares
do you see Magritte they're making
macGruber - I did get that now the movie
was pretty good I don't know if you
think I don't know if it's like God tear
that Dan makes it but I think it's
really good yeah okay so wait no no go I
got this oh yeah so put the Queen in
there maybe this is just that's Queen
the bottom one is Queen right no ask the
king
yeah
so now can you go right no back you want
to get that flamethrower that's over
there I go through that right no I know
so go go back to where you put the Queen
plug in take the Queen plug out yeah
you're left like back down this long
hallway and you should be able to put
the Queen in there and then the King to
get the flamethrower and then yeah I
know I know but but put the Queen in
there now that you have the King you
should be able to get the flamethrower
now the King should be at the end of the
yes yeah there's your fourth weapon yay
oh yeah it's all so I'm gonna flame
tower that's Leon's it's a spark so now
I believe yeah unlock that okay mmm just
leave out that door I'll just go get
thick both plug shadow scared
and now I can just get the plugs yeah I
don't I mean you're done here you just
gotta make sure you get the plugs oh you
should be able to go get the I mean I
can't oh yeah so go pick up the king put
that back in there
wait
yeah hey you should be good I gotta
clean and like whoo nothing I thought
you're cool yeah all right so put but go
back to the one you were looking at no
[ __ ] you got to get into the
flamethrower room I know so put the
Queen in this one right there yeah I
think I've got it
Queen yeah now go through the
flamethrower room [ __ ] okay um I don't
think this is right I don't think it's
you just are you very interesting oh
yeah that's the that's supposed to be
the kidding right
oh wait [ __ ] turn around I just put the
king in here all right all right
like go go to the one to the right I
want to see what that says on it King
right king plug yeah okay
King the Queen you want to leave it in
here I think
why don't I want to put one in here yeah
maybe that's it Queen drugs solid way no
you bet you need those too when you
leave I think I think he did solve it
we're just dancing around it
oh yeah yeah now okay yes okay yeah
that's why I was gonna say thank you hey
but drives are wearing off
all right yeah that's what I was gonna
say at all times
am i injured I'm on caution from those
gross little doodads wait do I have to
go back through that [ __ ] hole mm-hmm
can I just go back a different way I
have to go through the eye room um I
have to go through the eye room the eye
room like the the sewer they got big eye
yeah but you can dodge them what do you
mean I can't dodge them
there's too many there's three to kill
you killed one you could kill one of
demonic
you can use the spark shot now but it's
a pretty effective what is it how does
it work
just shoots a spark sorry alright well
show you [ __ ] go for it yeah all
right [ __ ]
no you don't yet it's the point yeah
yeah yeah you're good
I'm gonna say it don't cry I'm telling
you I not come back here you do but like
right now I wouldn't worry about it
just go just go past latter letter yeah
you know you're fine he can't no no
don't shoot him
it just looks like a penis yeah oh I
noticed I know you notice let me change
the guns before accidentally like shoot
electricity up someone's wazoo here no
head yeah more like no head
do you mind if we save ya oh there ya go
up right you came from upstairs
yeah it's like right across here yeah
and we'll just do a little longer one
next time or something yeah yes I'm
going to meet up for those wondering I'm
going to meet up with goo bara
he was official unofficial number one
fan that's Erica Tech always said mhm
and now that I'm in New York I can see
him he's lives he's from Long Island
yeah like a fan art everybody it was
awesome whoa is that as big on your
screen as and we will see you again on
the next Resident Evil thanks a lot guys
president Knievel see ye wait cut back
to me stop the East stop the outro
[Laughter]